let's read this first story and talk
about what's going on here in the
capitol with nancy pelosi
the story from timcast.com house arrests
capitol police instructed to arrest
staff and visitors
not wearing face masks a new memo
circulated on capitol hill this week
after the cdc revised its guidelines for
vaccinate americans
instructing police to arrest visitors
and staff
who refuse to wear face masks in certain
areas
quote although this applies to the
members of congress
officers should not arrest any member
for failure to wear a mask
or to comply with the mask mandate the
guidance states any member who fails to
comply with a request to wear a mask
should be reported to the house sergeant
at arm's office
quote this is such an overstep of
speaker pelosi's authority to basically
make our capital police arrest staff
members
and report on members of congress rep
kat
kamek told fox news thursday it's
absolutely unconscionable
that this is where we're at i cannot
comply with tyrannical order chemic edit
this is the people's house not nancy
pelosi's house
the speaker of the house does not
control the us capitol police
pelosi spokesperson drew hamill told fox
news we were unaware of the memo
until it was reported to the press quote
if you're a capital police officer you
got orders
if a vaccinated staffer comes comes
across in the house side without a mask
you're ordered to arrest them but not on
the senate side
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
said this is not the america we know
so we're seeing that uh steve steve
scalise said it was pelosi directing
police to arrest vaccinated people
and ike you know they're saying she
doesn't control the police
they didn't that's a non-denial denial
yeah saying oh but she doesn't control
the police yes but you can go to them
and say i've ordered all masters to be
worn and they said okay all right we'll
go arrest him so there's a big
difference between her
controlling them and instructing what
the rules are
i can't imagine that it's not pelosi
because if it was the capital police
making this decision
then the senate side would be equally as
affected which it's not
i'm just glad democrats have found found
some policing to approve of i i would
think that you know they could send in
some social workers here
to get the masking on but i don't know
why we need to get the police and the
sergeant-at-arms involved
actually i mean that would be a
brilliant stunt to be hilarious right
yeah like matt gates is walking through
the house chamber or whatever
and then a social worker comes out and
like takes a knee and says like matt
is something wrong but they don't know
how they don't know how to do funny
things like that
i'll tell you what this story really
freaked me out because
it it's it's dangerously close to
you know it's dangerously close to an
old story
of a man being caned in congress you
know the story yeah back during the
civil war
there was a caning that one rap was like
beating the other for the game now i
don't think nancy plays gonna come out
beat anybody
and i'm not suggesting anyone's gonna be
violent what i'm saying is we're getting
dangerously close to the point where
someone would apply force against
another member of congress now i i
understand it said
don't arrest a member of congress what
about the staffers yeah
so that means you're gonna here's what
you end up seeing
you're gonna have marjorie taylor greene
or matt gates or
lauren bobert not wearing masks saying
we refuse
and their staffers are going to be
forced to win under threat of arrest
i imagine many of them are going to say
no and so we're getting dangerously
close to that point where members of
congress
well particularly this would be the
democrats trying to exert force
over their political opposition that's
that's not going to go anywhere good
yeah and for what like for
not wearing a piece of cloth over their
faces after
almost all of them have been vaccinated
like what are we doing here
well i think that's also like they did
this big splashy thing with the arrests
and it's about something really stupid
well i i think the issue is no one has
any idea what's going on anymore
yeah this is uh a lot of people are
pointing out that part of demoralization
you guys have seen the yuri bezmanov
thing i'm sure we could
we get suggested it like 50 times a day
um
one of the things that happens is
there's mass media
that gives out so much contradictory
information no one has any idea what's
going on anymore
yeah and this is where we've been for a
long time so there's a really great
example i tweeted out
the media hates you and thinks you're
stupid because almost every single major
outlet said black lives matter does not
spread
you know protests were not spreading
covet but then right-wing protests were
and now you have many on the left who
are just like protests don't spread it
but then just believe that the
right-wing ones do
and there's just every and it's elevated
beyond that right now so one of the
things we were bringing up earlier is
cdc guidance we were talking about
pregnant women and i was like the
guidance says that you can get it if
you're pregnant and then you mentioned i
guess
yeah that in april they released
guidance on a friday
saying that pregnant women should get
the vaccine and then they walked it back
on the monday and said pregnant women
could get the vaccine
but that's a big change right so all the
women that got it saturday and sunday
who were pregnant or like what
like what did i just do um i shouldn't
could or
a giant difference yeah now they say
that
they recommend it but that women who may
be pregnant want to be pregnant or are
pregnant need to talk to their doctors
because obviously there's very specific
and different things that could affect a
person
and everyone's got different health and
i think that applies to everybody to be
honest
the problem is it's what i was stating
earlier when it comes to these masks
when it comes to
the lockdown policies all the stuff if
you have the cdc like fauci
flip-flopping like he was yeah
what happens when a journalist writes a
story
and it's based on the information from
friday and not monday right
i mean yeah the story from friday stays
up it's not like they take it down right
it's um but yeah the thing the things
making no sense
is i think directly responsible for uh
people not getting vaccinated i i
have an acquaintance a mom of three just
teenage kids
you know i think she'd be kind of a
typical person who would go get
vaccinated and she's like no because in
spring 2020 when everything stopped
making sense i stopped trusting
everything that they were saying
and so i don't want to get vaccinated
and i don't want my kids to get
vaccinated and i'm not doing that
when kamala harris and i think even joe
biden i'm not sure about kamala yeah and
a bunch of other people came out and
they were
yeah and they were they were disparaging
the idea of these vaccines
and i you know as much as the these
these twitter audi lunatics don't want
to accept it
a lot of people saw them say that and
said make sense to me sure
and then see a complete 180 and they're
probably going uh
what right but it was like as if trump
was like in the backyard of the white
house like mixing up like
you know the vaccines by himself like oh
no we're gonna need to see like evidence
like no [ __ ]
you're gonna need to see evidence you
know this is such an example of why you
sh
in my opinion you shouldn't politicize
medical you know
emergencies and and especially why
that you shouldn't centralize a response
to a medical emergency like putting all
power in one guy's hands
doesn't make sense but but no one did it
on purpose the foundation yeah the
voucher thing was like
it was it was well i shouldn't say that
own it on purpose it was that the media
wanted their anti-trump narrative or
whatever
so they were like fouchy's the guy we'll
we'll we'll we'll champion this guy
and then inadvertently the tv doctor
became the uh
uh the the end-all be-all i suppose and
now and now
you know the crazy thing is the cdc has
changed
its its opinions numerous times now what
they say is
well fauci said well it's science
science
okay okay here's the problem you
mentioned this the story from friday
stays up it doesn't go away so one day
i'm reading facebook as hypothetical
and i scroll across a story and it's
from like a day or two ago
and they say dr fauci says you gotta
wear two masks because of the droplets
and then so i read and i'm like oh okay
and then some other person
reads the story from the next day fauci
says no no there's no reason to wear too
much
this actually happened fauci was on a
show and i think it was
and they say like why are you wearing
two masks without you said we should
right no he didn't he said we shouldn't
like what are you talking about i just
read the news yesterday he said we
should dude
the story came out this morning he said
no you're crazy i read it in the new
york times
yeah but he's also a uniquely bad
communicator he's so
terrible at this role and so is the cdc
head rochelle wallansky they're both
horrible at conveying a message and
sticking to that message they change
their mind all the time i've written
about it again and again
where they say one thing one day and
another thing another day and sometimes
it is
because it's politicized sometimes it's
because they sat down with the teachers
union and had to rewrite the whole
messaging on schools but sometimes it's
just they don't know what they're
talking about
um i saw fauci that right after um
the cdc released guidance that
vaccinated people
don't have to wear masks and also
unvaccinated people didn't have to wear
masks outside
um savannah guthrie was like but what
about my kid my kid
has to wear a mask outside and thatcher
was like yeah your kid has to wear a
mask outside but there was nothing in
the cdc guidance that said that he
literally like read it to her
and i was like but he's saying you don't
have to wear it and they both just
agreed that the kid had to wear it and
that was it
you know i noticed about fauci last year
is that he just repeats what the media
says
yeah like i don't i think he doesn't
actually right no
and a lot of the guidance it's it's this
cyclical effect that eventually spirals
out of control and just
just just bursts he'd say something like
you know he had that story whereas like
that famous interviewer says you don't
need to be walking around with a mask
because you might stop a droplet or two
and then he changes his tune later yeah
but his tune changes like a day after
the news reports
something so the news it's like a study
says x y and z and then also need to
come out and say it
right but that's also the me sorry the
media never asks him
what changed he's always like the
science change but okay what was it what
what was the study what was the study
that changed your mind where like if
kovid was too small to be contained by
the mask when you said that
did covet grow did the masks improve
actually the masks we got worse
we started wearing t-shirts over our
faces right so you know
if we had a competent media we would get
normal answers but what we have now is
just
not that did you see the twitter video
finally came out the mashup of fouchy
you don't need a mask
oh you need two masks your children do
not need to wear masks you definitely
gotta put a mask on your child
like crazy it's like a minute long of
just contradiction contradiction
contradiction
he's the guy right this is this is who
we're relying on
yeah joe rogans had to listen to fouchy
and i was like joe no
like listen to him but you don't have to
believe and do everything he says
i think aristotle said it's a brilliant
man a sign of a brilliant man is someone
that can entertain a thought without
believing it
right yeah that's a good one yeah talk
to your doctor
definitely you're not about to talk to
many doctors this is
that's the issue fauci has said so many
contradictory things you need
i i know a lot of people they email me
and they're like tim doctors don't know
more than most people or whatever and
i'm like dude then get a better doctor
like find the smart one yeah okay like
i'm not the smartest person in the world
i i was you know like uh there's one one
of the ingredients in the vaccine pro
was it probably glycol no no no no no
it's um
uh pro pro ethylene pro-ethylene glycol
i think it's called i'm like i don't
i know what glycol is a little bit i've
read a bit about it i'm gonna go ask a
doctor about these things
because i didn't go to school and you
know there there are certain medications
that have certain adverse effects you
should look them up and you should talk
to somebody
and if you got a dumb doctor look you
can get a dumb plumber i've hired bad
carpenters
and i'm like how are these people
actually carpenters you know yeah so
it's like
that that's the main issue that everyone
that we're all dealing with is i think
we're i was thinking about this earlier
it's uh it's obviously information
overload
because that that's that that thing we
talked about with the cdc changing it's
and updating its guidelines
is everything literally everything yeah
so there is uh ryan long you know ryan
long comedian
he did a really great bit about this
where he was like
you know you can you can find an article
for literally anything
claiming something is racist and he
shows like articles that will claim
something is or isn't racist at the same
time like back and forth
because there's an article for literally
everything so what happens
when someone says something like i know
that x
equals one and they google it and they
find five thousand articles saying x
equals one and they're like
look at all this then the other guy
across the table says it's x equals two
and then pulls up five thousand articles
so we're just being driven insane yeah
and it shows
yeah i don't know how we escaped i just
looked up whale hunting racists
oh yeah there are obviously it's racist
yes yeah thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you